drag is about empowerment we travel
across this country to take people from
who they are to what they can be
this project has always spoken directly
to my heart
because i grew up in a small
conservative town and being able to have
the opportunity to travel around america
and amplify voices in small conservative
towns queer voices tell the stories the
struggles the triumphs all of that is a
gift to me going into these small
conservative towns i must imagine for
you by the time you leave you just must
feel this incredible sense of wow we did
that we changed some people's
perceptions of the queer community and
the art form of drag i'll never forget
after evansville indiana
[Music]
sorry
he's had to exist in this world of fear
what made you want to do drag here i
don't want to hide no more i don't want
to conceal no more me and luscious my
makeup artist sat in the car and we just
cried
and we were just so happy for case from
the time that we had met him when we
first got there just seeing him blossom
and then seeing you know him come out
and embrace all of who he was you know
through his drag character and through
the stage performance and hearing that
audience like
in a place where he always felt isolated
you know
and afraid so many times to have the
courage to be on stage and to perform
and to feel that spirit of community
that he didn't know existed
[Applause]
and to see that
and know that we had a a part in that
was like
it was just beautiful